hello we begin in the United States
where the White House has confirmed a
second set of classified documents have
been found found this time at President
Joe Biden's private residence in
Delaware earlier this week it was
revealed that classified documents were
found at Biden's former office at a
Washington think tank in November this
latest Discovery could prove to be a
political embarrassment for the Biden
Administration the documents are
believed to be from the time when he
served as vice president authorities are
investigating a bigger Scandal involving
former president Donald Trump's alleged
mishandling of classified documents
people know I take classified documents
and classify materials seriously
I also said we're cooperating fully and
completely the Justice Department's
review
as part of that process my lawyers
reviewed other places where documents in
my uh of from my time as vice president
were stored and they finished the review
last night
they discovered a small number of
documents of classified markings and
storage areas and file cabinets in my
home and my in my my personal Library
well the Republican house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy has called for an investigation
they knew this has happened to President
Biden before the election but they kept
it a secret from the American public he
goes on 60 Minutes criticizes president
Trump even knowing what he has done and
he wasn't president at the time now we
find another location that it's at but
he refused to answer his press secretary
won't answer the questions
we you watched them leak photos of
sitting out files of President Trump
where's the photos of President Biden's
documents where are those photos at he
knowingly knew this happened going into
election going into interviews this is
what makes America not trust their
government let's bring in our White
House correspondent Kimberly Halka
joining us from Washington D.C so tell
us more about the reaction that's been
coming through and what more we're
learning about this new batch of
documents that has now been found
well we know that this second batch of
documents was found as a result of a
search by White House Council of the two
residences belonging to current
President Joe Biden not only his private
residence in Wilmington Delaware but
also his beach house in the same state
and while there was nothing found at the
beach house there were documents found
as a result of that search that finished
just late last evening in the private
garage of the president now the
President says he has no idea what are
in these documents just as he maintains
he has no idea what their the documents
contained in that first batch that was
found in the Penn Biden Center they also
say the White House maintains that these
documents have been turned over to the
National Archives and they believe that
this is an important distinction as you
contrast this to the documents they
allege were mishandled by former
president Donald Trump that this is the
important difference in these two two
cases the fact that the White House
alleges that the former president may
have set himself up for obstruction of
justice given the fact that it was a
subpoena that was required to retrieve
those documents but still the
president's critics are seizing upon
this case saying that given the fact
that both men have now had documents
found at their private homes that the
president's criticisms of the former
president calling him totally
irresponsible is nothing more than
hypocrisy now we should point out that
we are expecting to hear from the
Department of Justice specifically the
Attorney General Merrick Garland he is
expected to speak coming up around 19
GMT this is something that is important
given the fact the White House has been
referring all questions on this matter
to the Department of Justice so we will
continue to hear more about not only the
case involving the current president but
potentially the former one as well all
right thank you so much Kimberly Hall
reporting from the White House